The time between the election and the inauguration is called the transition.
The new president assembles an administration...
...and prepares to start running the federal government.
The job is run by a transition team, separate from the campaign,...
...with its own staff and budget.
The transition team develops goals and strategies...
...for the early days of the new administration.
Here's what is to be decided:...
...how to turn campaign promises into policy,...
...what to do first and what to do later...
...and whether to roll back actions of the previous president.
The federal government provides office space and financial resources needed to do the work.
It also does background checks for security clearances.
Private donors are allowed to contribute to the transition,...
...up to the limit of 5,000 dollars per person.
Rapidly-decided elections give the transition team about 11 weeks,...
...but the contested 2000 election ended with only 39 days remaining.
Ready or not, a president will be sworn in at noon on  January 20th.
With a smooth transition, the new president can have a team in place,...
...ready to work on a new agenda.